♫ ["Goodbye Yellow Brick Road"
by Elton John] ♫
SCOTT LANG
I used to ask myself a lot of questions.
Scott, you're an ex-con...
How are you an Avenger?
That doesn't make sense.
But everywhere I go,
people tell me the same thing.
CAFE OWNER
Thank you, Spider-Man!
CASSIE LANG
People still need help, Dad.
That's why we made this.
It's like a satellite for
deep space, but Quantum!
JANET VAN DYNE
Wait, wait a minute.
You're sending a signal
down to the Quantum Realm?
Turn it off, now!
[Screaming]
CASSIE LANG
Dad?
SCOTT LANG
Cassie!
♪♪
CASSIE LANG
Where... are we?
♫ When are you gonna come down?
When are you going to land? ♫
♫ I should have stayed on the farm
I should have listened to my old man ♫
JANET VAN DYNE
It's a secret universe beneath ours.
HOPE VAN DYNE
What are you so afraid of?
JANET VAN DYNE
There's something I never told you.
KANG
This place...
...it isn't what you think.
♫ Oh, I've finally decided my future lies
Beyond the yellow brick road ♫
♪♪
KANG
I can get you home...
...and give you more time...
...if you help me.
KANG
So, what's it gonna be...
...Ant-Man?
♪♪